ん
あった
voodoo
はい
ます
th
皆さん
こんにちは
あの音はここで道を見ていただこうと思ったんですけども
僕はあの
ダンスを持っています
perl ん
女優の
杉本が入っちゃいます
すごいでしょ水後ダイザー
こんな感じでー
こ
を
ダイキ次いでございましたね
この辺了解もぱレイアウト開封
するが置いておきましてですね part 2会おう
これあのあモーニング娘
ダンスを始めて僕は
30分の所は27歳からダンスを始めたんですけども
まあいいことも悪いことも
一杯生きてきました
ダンスを通してモーニング娘と
振り付け担当したんですけどね
矢口は可愛かったなぁ
安田はブサイクだったぁー
あとアフターフォローするとかね一粒三島
歌っているの子で思っ
これメイクですけど腰を学ぶ
ちゃん the ご試聴コーナーを
前はファイバーの刑務所に入ってますけどもね
あのをしようたろうさんだから低 rf
てやる
にっ
方と踊っています
まずしま
はなん
あのまあとしてまたご者は私のとこ
松島トモ子とも訓練間ずっとあの
撮ってたんですけども松島トモ子知らない人
はい
ないように首を噛まれた調印
順番は猿なんだいたい家帰って聴いてください大女優ですからこの方と一緒に
4年間乾燥してきまして
ブロンドこれ私パターンちゃうんですけどもあの
こういう社交ダンスの国
思っております
で上げちゃん後にチャンピオンにも生まれました
[拍手]
プロフィアシュワブが入っ
チャンピオンございましたーーー
ok
いきますねまあいろんなことがありましたねっ
あの
僕はあっ
ダンサーになりたかったんじゃなかったです
ぷろーど亭さん
なんじゃなかった
16歳年
アイク思っ
鈴鹿サーキット
走っていました
そして
17歳
このころになるとあ
プロボレーサーになりたいなぁ
[音楽]
そんな夢を持って
18歳
高校卒業したら
プロ御礼菜んだろっ
これが僕の
大きな夢です
でも
その夢は
一緒にして
なくなります
事故をしてしまい
火がついたら
病院のベッドに
1週間ほどっ
あれ
足動かな
うやらない
はいば両方つけていっ
口だが
ここから血が滲み出し
花火はさんっ
原画展でいっ
先生
分かっ
あっ俊吾奇抜
ではありません
助けてくださん
いくら金でも
いくら叫んでも
あなたの足は
にどこ
動きません
一生
車椅子生活です
いや俺山両陛下はあっ
一斉洗車
助けで助けてっ
いくらだいて6
何も変わらん
あの点滴のチューブに手が届いたら
した髪切ってるぞ
自殺紹介
あそこ尿意リアルアド車椅子に乗れたら
屋上いってと秒5差ずしよう
毎日そのためだけに
麦に力をつけましたそして
大変頭を
目の前にあったライフを持って
ています
粟田時間慌てて看護師さんがあって
何してもそんなことしちゃダメでしょ
いき盗んだよって
こぜ
殺してくれん
新ネタ日だっ
母親が
慌てて病室に行ってきて
大粒の涙を流しながら
辛いんだ
そんなにつがいだった
今から一瞬
&日のことは
を進めません
今では懐かしいん
記憶です
やっと大変できていっ
見えてきたものがあります
社会壁
表もテーマの
心のバリア9位
会えるも
この日本に会えるものは
何か乗っ
僕は木の街に乗って
この高さから見えたことがあります
不便の町
冷たい人
皆さんと一緒に考えたいと思います
何を会えれば
この冷たい人
不便な間違う
この日本から消えろっ
当たる前という言葉を頭の真ん中に置いてこれから
お話を聞いて欲しいと思う
さて
まずこの前つで一つ目困ったことを想像してください
う子
無効化後とどうなるか
うんこが上がってくる上がって下がって上がって下がって黒4の回ってにベチョッ杭
さあ
よく困っただろう
そして
階段
間は困りますねぇ
ダウンさも困ります
持つ時とするか
皆さんは
4人で凍ったらいいと思いますよね
でも僕は大阪から行ってきましたよ笑のおっさんに頼んだらどこを打つか
ここ持ち寄った
俺はええけどたまにスプーンで脱げるをサーブから危ない危ない
ちゃうと
思ったらいいですかと聞いています
そして
ああ
断ってもいい場合があります
こういう場合は断りましょう
めっちゃ急な階段
あと二つ
ありますそれが
発信を
そして
ピザ1
こういう場合は断ってください
ああそうですね
はい軟弱なンって日本ねこういう場合同社になるん
スロー海岸はいどうしたらいいと思いますか
そちらの方に行きましょうかね
の方ん
こういうこの男性の方ですかはいっ
こういう場合はどうする
はい失礼
応援はあっちに行きましょうかねぇ
でもねそんな名前なんていうんですか
今ちゃんにはちゃんに質問がありますね
きょう午後に来るときにですね
スロープ手前に
これだけのダンスがあったんです
どうしたらよろしいでしょうか
これの200
登りいいが彼の手前に段差が
僕段差
どうしたらいいんでしょうか
後で考えましょう
えっ
そんながあってですねはい
おっ
点字ブロック
なんでそこで我んねーみたいな
これかっこんで真っすぐを打たれん
お気もは難しい
色々な問題が街にはたくさん
よ皆さん
こんな
ジャイ子でも
後ろをしてくれます
我が娘
まだ3歳の時
パパを慕うよう
うてくれましたん
にはちゃん
鷹山は困っている人いたときにはどうしますか
顔がアウト助けたん
合わなければ
うん
なるほどつまらん
昨日いましたここあり同販売機で役員を年出ると
中そこ
このかないから岩ちゃんのような男前のお兄ちゃんありました
すいません
直下をしてくださいっ
岩様
伊豆絣数もうデーショ殺しそう言ってはっ
ひどいですよね
顔が合ってなくても
いうことはあります
みんなねー
僕は両方の現場車っていう立場
障害者というたちが票を経験しています
声をかけるって言っ
メカ恥ずかしいですね
ね読むにはちゃ
声をかけれない自分を恥ずかしいと思っています
大丈夫ですがあったいっ
その行動力を身につけてほしい
当たり前の行動当たり前に思いあるって考えて行動をする
そんなこともね表面でまだ
人の姿勢にでのハイあの本当にであの
外に入れるといろんな方が車椅子に乗っていたら
追いかけてきます
おばあちゃんが
やってきた兄ちゃん
ちょい平野さ
心房しーあね
怖そうなおっさんがねきてああ
お前
i キャレ品のがバイブ路コンドムカイザー
これで美味しいもの食べるを避け
保険胸ポケットお札を1
美味しい食べられていたね
一番いい入れろ
にはちゃ
ご覧にならん
今ねはね払い birth by パパだして見えるけど
この1000円にどこ行ったろうか
マクドナルドにタウンマップどうなるといったものある人
この前の一番前の黄色い帽子をかぶったん
お兄さん
マクドナルドに行ったら
続ん
一番強い国小指たいなぁ
ここで a
どうぞおかけになってお待ちくださいをスワップんね
いろんなことがあります白後でいっぱいあります
でもね
ダンス一つにとっても辛いことがありましたん
ディスコ肉棒
中に聞いてもらえもらえなかっ
無駄に入ります
ダンススタジオデー
刻印ダンスを教えてくださいということ
そのスタジオ先生がこう言いましたお兄さーん
ダンスはね自分の足で踊るのがダンスなんだよ
真主将いうことがしておらんといて
そんなことを言われ続けてます
ダンス均にとっても辛い思い出があります
僕はどうしてダンスを始めたかというと
共有
増やしさんから
そして
海外で言うと
当たり前に学べて競い合えてい
そろえる
そういう環境があるということを言った時に
絶対にを飛び続け8
でも僕には
com 金とか配筋が変わりません
バランスを崩すと
どこがあったんです
takashi で一輪車に乗ってサドル歌って
表そうと思うそんなん
感じです
いやー腰でしょ1/1000のバランス de ダンスボールがあるのです
今日はせっかくなので最後に
南総で撮っ
終わったと思います kan
ああああああ
[拍手]
ん